Fox News is doing something that is evil
genius I have to hand it to them like
that it's actually genius what they are
doing if Fox News were to say we're not
going to talk about the impeachment
trial we're not going to show that there
is an impeachment trial going on they
would rightly be called out because that
would be completely absurd we've had
three presidents impeached in the
history of the United States Andrew
Johnson was in the 19th century before
we had 24-hour news and the internet and
satellite television and all of the
stuff the other was Bill Clinton in the
1990s and now we have Donald Trump not
covering impeachment would be crazy even
for Fox News they would be called out it
would not be something that they would
be able to to to bear so Fox News has
figured out a way to have impeachment on
the TV screen but not to really cover it
and to propagandize directly through the
impeachment proceedings yesterday the
impeachment managers the prosecutors as
they effectively are in the impeachment
of Donald Trump they had their first
three days of presenting their case it
was long it was nearly eight of their 24
hours that they have allocated for this
it was very nuanced and detailed and
there were exhibits videos tweets text
messages but Adam Schiff and the others
did a very good job of laying out the
big picture of Donald Trump's wrongdoing
starting to sort of lay out the arc of
it Fox News often showed it on mute
meaning without audio including going to
commercials while impeachment was going
on and they can say we covered it if you
turned on Fox News there were hours and
hours where you could see that
impeachment proceedings were going on
you couldn't hear it it was on the
screen though you couldn't hear what was
being said they ran commercials later
they ran right-wing commentary lying
about the content of the proceedings
while you could see but not hear the
proceedings so let's look at a few clips
I have a bunch of these here's a
commercial for some kind of bed linen or
pillow or something when Adam Schiff is
speaking about how the president
committed high crimes and misdemeanors
and should be removed from office each
and every one of you get the best sleep
of your life that's why I created my new
géza dreams bet she's I guarantee you
they'll be the most comfortable sheets
you'll ever own with now every Network
has commercials that by itself is not a
huge thing but this was all day here's
another example of when congresswoman
Val Demmings was laying out her part of
the narrative and as Aaron reparse said
on Twitter
Fox has the optics of covering the
impeachment trial without really
covering it they show the proceedings
with no audio while the hosts provide
frumpy and spin here's Jesse Watters
saying they should call hunter Biden to
the trial you get to call whoever you
want and one of the reasons you call
hunter is ask him what the hell he was
doing over there and why he was doing it
because that's why he was making that
phone call partially The Wall Street
Journal wrote I mentioned this in an
editorial that if you're arguing there
was a corrupt motive that that Trump had
then and if he was investigating Hunter
Byron's activities well let's explore
that and let's explore what hunter Biden
told his father the vice-president about
his business in Ukraine
let's ask Obama energy saw Amos
Hochstein who raised concerns about Joe
Biden and his aides about hunter Biden's
Ukrainian ties and then there was Chris
Hines former Secretary of State John
Kerry stepson broke business with hunter
Biden because of his work with Purisima
he called it unacceptable so let's let's
cover all that just really quickly hey
they covered it right I mean you
couldn't hear a damn word that was said
you could only hear pro Trump spin and
conspiracy theories but it was on the
screen you could see Val Demmings moving
her mouth there then at night mind you
this was still while the proceedings
were going on because they went from
about one to nearly 9:45 p.m. Eastern
Time Sean Hannity instead of showing you
what Adam Schiff is saying sums up the
proceedings as we learned nothing at all
and there's nothing notable here and
Adam Schiff looked like a crazy person
manufacturing consent telling you what
to think after a full day of telling you
what to think here's what you missed
from today's schumer chef shams show
charade made it again we learned
absolutely nothing new today not one new
piece of information instead we got
and hours and hours literally of the
compromised corrupt congenital liar Adam
Schiff Wow never-ending non-stop feigned
moral outrage and then here's Tucker
Carlson also again the proceedings were
still going on
just ridiculing the entire thing right
there the Senate impeachment trial is
still going it's been in progress all
day they would be forgiven if you didn't
watch every single minute of it imagine
a movie written and directed by children
whose ending you already know and by the
way it's 20 hours long
in Hungarian with misspelled subtitles
that's what it's like we've been
monitoring it anyway all day because
that's what we do and we'll alert you if
anything interesting happens during this
hour so understand you could watch Fox
News all day and in some technical sense
you'd be watching the impeachment trial
except you would have heard commercials
for my pillow
instead of Adam Schiff you would have
heard Jesse Watters and Egan McDowell
talk about we got to get hunter Biden to
testify as if that's what this is really
about and then you would be able to
finish out the day with Tucker Carlson
and Sean Hannity spoon-feeding you that
you didn't miss anything
all the impeachment managers are making
fools out of themselves and there's
nothing to see here whatsoever these are
full on propaganda tactics okay yeah
this is how you end up with people who
say Trump did nothing wrong did you
watch the trial though you would say to
them and they'd say you know I did I
watched the trial but did you hear
anything that they said or did you see
Adam shifts mouth moving while Tucker
Carlson and Sean Hannity told you there
was actually nothing to see here well no
I guess I watched it but I didn't really
hear anything but Trump definitely did
nothing wrong it's a very sad state of
affairs and it's part of reinforcing
when Republicans ultimately vote to
acquit everybody will feel trumpets I
mean that they did the right thing a Fox
News viewer on the day that the
acquittal of Donald Trump happens they
will hear Trump was acquitted and they
will think back to you know I remember
watching on Fox News and
I didn't hear anything damning about
Donald Trump during the trial
well Fox ran it on mute while their
commentators told you that there was
nothing to see here
and then they'll think you had the
Republicans voted the right way because
I don't remember hearing anything very
damning about what Donald Trump did
manufacturing consent it's out of a
textbook and the story of how right-wing
media is handling this is a huge part of
the story and when the history of this
is written I hope that's included with
with Andrew Johnson's impeachment of
course the technology wasn't there to
manufacture consent in this way with
Bill Clinton's impeachment well that was
the impeachment of a Democrat so the
rules are completely completely
different when it comes to how
right-wing media will cover it and of
course we didn't have social media then
like we do now this is a huge event for
the United States of America in and of
itself but the manufacturing of consent
the media narratives the spin are a huge
part of it and we can't forget that let
me know what you think about how Fox
News has been covering this I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman follow me on Twitter
at D Pakman and let me know what you
make of how the write has been covering
the impeachment of Donald Trump so
you're someone who enjoys thinking about
politics you love learning about
countless other topics but you just
don't have enough time in your week to
read or listen to all the books you've
been meaning to get to blink astiz an
app that will completely transform the
way that you absorb information and
ideas because what they do is take
thousands of non-fiction books extract
the most important insights and
information and then present each book
to you as text or audio which you can
consume in just 15 minutes
imagine how well-rounded you will become
once you have the ability to read five
books in one sitting or listen to a new
book on your commute every day obviously
we should read the full versions of
books whenever we can it's what I try to
do but it is a reality that there's a
whole world of books out there that you
will never get to but blinka swill help
you get to more
I just finished listening to the way we
eat now by bee Wilson whose work I've
recommended to you before super
interesting look at how the global food
system
works and impacts the way that we live
you'll be able to have conversations
with people about totally new topics you
can feed your curiosity in ways that
you've never been able to before and the
best part is it's only about eight bucks
a month which gives you unlimited access
to every single book in their catalogue
they have books on politics economics
philosophy science you name it you can
try it out yourself totally free for a
week and get 25% off if you decide to
subscribe just by going to blink is comm
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video like the rest of
us I bet you're going into 2020 thinking
about what you didn't get around to in
2019 and your goals for the new year if
you want to work towards being your best
self in 2020 understand more about the
world around you and make sure that your
time is well spent then blink astiz for
you